il en arrive tous souviens d'une chanson
qui s'appelait je crois comme les stars
que tu avais écrites pour iliad monte
l'équipe qui passait qui était une
mesure vue aux folies bergères et avec
le garantis comme directeur est ce que
tu t'en souviens je crois qu'il avait
fait un tableau d'ailleurs de tache en
son nom mais je vais la jouer je serai
je suis aimable
maintenant c'était un but assez violent
ça
[Musique]
chez toi tu écoutes
quoi qu'est le quatre genres de musique
jeunes improvisent sais pas quoi ça
dépend si je suis de mauvaise humeur
je suis de bonne humeur c'est
[Musique]
oui
raconte moi ton meilleur souvenir
souvenirs souvenirs c'est quand j'ai
rencontré ma petite femme et
nous étions à table
et enfin si rennes ancien que je
quittais
e
plus
et puis les les pieds sous frôlait les
jeunes aux pollens de son lait
c'était chaud et c'est chouette gars m'a
donné mon pierre fall et le genou de 7
pouces quitter sa secte et plus tôt
et c'était tout
et l'amour dans tout ça l'amour c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
du
l'amour c'est sans fin c'est comme ça
sont des vapeurs plus tôt et dieu dans
tout ça
dieu est
e
wagner et quel est l'état présent de ton
esprit avec les tirades que j'ai au
théâtre c'est beaucoup plus
mais dans quelques jours ce sera
[Musique]
alors il pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez
un peu de bleu